Hey, welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
Do you remember our can roof?
So many of you were wondering
how it would sound with the rain, so here it is!
In this update we
will do 3 different things.
We will maintain the lagoon of our neighbors,
we will work
a lot in our pig trailer and
we will do something
related with this toilet.
Keep on watching if
you want to see what happens.
But first, we´ll start by the laggon.
In the beginning of the
season we cleared the lagoon area.
We took all the mud out of the lagoon to
make it a nice
place to cool down in summer.
It has served us very well, not
only for us but also for the plants.
Now the summer is over and a lot of fast
growing plants sprouted
and took over the place again.
These wild grapes are climbing the trees.
Even in the bottom
of the waterfall, where
the soil got
exposed to the sun, these kind
of plants took over.
Also here, and in the pathways, and in
the terrace, our yellow gate got all dirty.
And accessing the lagoon from
this side is not possible anymore.
It is now a wall of cane.
And on top of that we also
lost a lot of water due to evaporation.
That's where the water used to be!
We lost a lot like almost 20 centimeters.
So let's start at the bottom.
So today we're
going to start removing all
of these overgrown
vines, some leftover wood
that is here and just
making this place a bit nicer.
Debbie, what did you find?
I found a huge tree!
It is huge!
It was actually a
super huge chestnut, it was dead.
And Jaime cut it and made
this lovely bridge with chestnuts.
Wow!
As you can see, we
have now cleared this area.
And we are now going to
start clearing the area over there.
The good thing is, you can take a
dip in the lagoon every 10 minutes or so.
It's nice.
Now it's time to remove this sketchy
dam that Dave built last year, sorry Dave.
We are doing this because when we cleared the lagoon,
all the sand got stuck between the dam.
To make this flow away in
winter, we are removing these rocks.
One, two, three!
Nice!
Are you done?
Yeah.
Done with the dam?
Obviously we wouldn't skip the
opportunity to clean the yellow gate.
As you can see, it got a bit dirty.
Full of algae.
We removed the dam, we cleaned
the door and also a bit the wall.
Now it's a much nicer place to
enjoy and let the winter do its thing.
So dangerous.
So we already worked on the lower area.
Now it's time to work on
the path to access the lagoon.
As you can see,
plants are growing all over.
You have to walk around them, some are
spiky, so it's way
better if you have all of this.
Nice and clean, easy access for barefoot
people, for normal
people to get to the lagoon.
What happened Doris?
A thorn got stuck on my feet
This is why we are doing this.
A bit better now,
there is more room to go through.
Because this rock was always in the way.
Done.
So as you can see, it looks already much
better, much
cleaner, way easier to access.
Nice for the feet.
So as you can see, this
part looks now much cleaner.
Now we have more areas to lay
down, to rest, it just looks much nicer.
As you saw in the last lagoon update, we
built these lovely
terraces here and we put inside
the soil that we took from the lagoon.
It's really fertile soil
for the grass and everything that
we want to plant, but it's
also really good for all of this.
So today we are going
to clean all of this and plant
some grass to slowly make
this into a nice grass terrace.
It's done?
Yes, the things we can do
with the brushcutter are done.
Now we have to go by hand and
remove the climmbing plants for the trees.
Trees are being eaten alive by these...
Yeah, they grow really fast.
You can see it's slowly taking
over the tree, so I have to manage it a bit.
That's what these plants do.
They can really take over.
You cannot pull because it's
stuck, so you have to unwind it a bit.
So as you can see, this
one had a little accident and it
just broke down, probably a
disease or it was too weak here.
But you can see already
some shoots here and also this
one, so we can basically
chop off this one and let it grow up.
So with the ones
that we chopped down from this
willow, we are going
to stake them into the ground.
Hopefully they will grow new trees.
Ooh, deep.
As deep as we can, we are putting them almost all in the same place.
So we have more
probabilities of just adding new trees.
So it's done.
Hopefully next year
we'll have growing willows here.
So we have already
cleared all this area and
now we want to start
putting some grass patches.
So we will prepare the soil a little
bit first, loose for this big patch of grass.
So they have, hopefully
we'll have new grass patches.
So now that we are
finished on this side, we
are going to start
working on the other side.
This is the other side, as
you can see, completely overgrown.
You can barely see the
steps that we worked so hard to make.
It's just time to brushcut
and show the beauty that it has.
As it is now, we cannot
access the lagoon from this side.
All of this cane
grew only within one year.
I would say very invasive.
And there are also many native trees in
this area that are
almost covered by the cane.
Currently we cannot even
reach the figs from the fig tree.
Enough reason to take the cane out.
So we have cleared
that side of the lagoon.
We chopped all the canes that
were there, removed some of their roots.
But the roots were
holding all the soil there.
So we have here some
willow prunings that we did.
So what we are going to do is
putting them on the soil horizontally.
And hopefully we'll have a lot
of trees growing from just one stick.
Some of the eyes where the shoots of
the trees will grow need to be facing upwards.
There are some here.
So we can let them facing upwards.
And we will just cover it.
The likelihood of these two to
sprouts is still a little bit low.
So we are staking as much as possible.
And I'm also going to
put some of them vertically.
So this patch is done.
I'm going to do it on
the other side and also up top.
So we have better ground support.
And yeah, it's done for now.
So before the
summer we cleared the lagoon.
Most of the dirt that we
moved we built a lovely terrace there.
But we also sent a lot of mud
and sand downstream down the waterfall.
Most of the mud and sand that
came down got stuck between the rocks.
Combined with the water and the heat and
sand from the summer
made this huge jungle here.
So now before the
winter comes and a lot of
water will flow we are
going to help out the stream
by cleaning this a bit and
make it look nice for the next season.
Looking good!
We are almost done.
First we thought let's clean it by
hand but then we thought of something better.
We had some rain
past week, actually a lot,
And the lagoon
filled up, we can do a big
flushing operation to leave it shiny.
And because this is such an important
and dramatic event we brought some fans and
expectators to join the show.
Coming, coming!
It's like this, a bit more, a bit more.
The first maintenance
job of the waterfall is done.
Finding the balance
between taking and careing
is not an easy task
but we will get the hang of it.
The place feels way
nicer and more easy to access.
The first autumn
rains filled up the lagoon.
So in these last hot days we can
spread the towels on the terrace again.
All together ready for the winter season.
So finally we have all the
materials for the roof to finish it.
Because in case you
didn't know now we have this
funky looking trailer
laying around in our land.
This used to be a pig
trailer, I know it's hard to believe now.
Finally we have our pig trailer here
ready to be transformed into a new house.
So we already built all
the structure, insulated and in the
last video we covered in
these lovely colors as you can see.
Now we are finishing the roof.
So Colline and me are
gonna kill it and finish the roof.
So let's go.
We have this first layer
which is only the vapor barrier.
With the rain here I just saw
one hole where the rain went through.
So right now we're
gonna start with the roof.
We're gonna make a frame all around
where we're gonna put the insulation in.
And then we're gonna
put a tarp over it and over
that we're gonna place
the battens and then the roof.
So right now we're
gonna install the frame first.
We're gonna put the last beam.
And you're gonna
put the most beautiful one.
Yes, it's all broken.
It's all broken.
Done.
Okay, so we have the whole frame in.
So right now what we're gonna do is
put all the insulation in between those spaces.
It's gonna be two layers
but we first have to cut some
little pieces because it's
just a bit bigger than two sheets.
Just on this side where it's
shadow you can see it's still a bit wet.
So yeah, 20 minutes will be dry and then
we can start
putting all the insulation in.
Okay, good stuff.
I'm gonna put the last piece
so I can say to my mom that I helped.
Good materials.
Yeah, I need to not be allergic to
dust, but like it's better than my bed.
If you are looking for a
hard worker, there you have it.
Hire me.
So the insulation is done.
Right now we're gonna start
putting the tarp on for the waterproof layer.
Yeah, we use this material.
It's 80% recycled textile.
Yeah, it's just a lot of fabric
turned apart and compressed together.
I think it's gonna work. We'll
see if it's a good insulation or not.
New material that we're trying out.
As we mentioned before, this
insulation cannot get water in, which is a bit of a
bummer because it requires
all these extra plastic layers.
Pretty far.
This one is to prevent the water
from getting in, but it lets humidity get out.
Next layer are this
batten to hold the foil.
And after to mount the roof sheets on
top.
So we finished the tarp and all the battens.
We taped off all
the screws on the battens.
And yeah, right now we're
gonna start putting the final roof in.
So for the roof of
our house, we're gonna choose
this corrugatal metal
sheet with insulation on it.
We're gonna cut them, bring them in
the pickup, put them on top of our house.
It's very light, very light.
We thought we were there
to get second hand sheets, but
actually they are just
the leftovers from the factory.
As they are not in
perfect condition, people
usually don't buy
them, but they still work for us.
This is a bit noisy, a bit disgusting.
Okay.
You have it?
All you. All you.
Yeah, this is the only shot we
have from the assembling of the roof.
A bit shaky, but you can see everything.
A little millimeter to me.
Okay, wait.
That's already good.
Last sheet.
Last sheet in place.
I just gotta mark
now where the screws go.
And I will start
drilling and putting the screws in.
Okay, so the roof is in.
Right now we're
gonna put the finished piece.
It's to cover the
exposed foam in the front and in
the back, but in the
back we have another piece here.
Which also prevents the
rain from coming under the battens.
First we're gonna install the
front and then we will install the big piece.
Okay, we're almost done with the roof.
We only need the
siding to be done because
we still see a bit of the anti-rain tarp.
So what we're gonna do is
we're gonna put some wood in there.
And sometime at kamp we don't have the
right tools for the
things that we want to do.
For example, here we
don't have a table saw yet.
So Julien made
this little guide handmade.
It will do for now.
It's not the official version,
but it suits for what we want to do.
And we can just saw all day long.
First we fix the battens on the
edges to screw the final pieces on top.
Then we cover the foil
and screw our last wood layer.
All around the trailer.
Okay, we're almost done with the roof.
But we still have one part to do.
We're a bit running out
of wood because all of the wood
that we're using is the
second hand not used from the sawmill.
So our quantities are limited.
So we're taking one
of these beams and instead
of using the length,
we're gonna use the width.
So I don't know how it's called in
English, but in French we call it "bardo".
It's to cut the reins
of the wood in this direction.
So we're cutting a bunch of
them and we're putting them together.
This way we can save
a bit of wood every time.
And that's what we
thought was the best for this one.
Let's see how it goes.
Okay, not perfect. Cool.
Okay, we're done
with the top part of the roof.
So that means that we are
completely done with the outside of the trailer.
Now we can focus more on the inside.
So you see with all of this that we
did on the outside, we have many left over.
The small ones are
gonna go for the pizza oven
as firewood and the
big one we will reuse later.
Maybe for inside middle wall.
Everything outside
of the trailer is done.
Now we focus on the inside.
It's very exciting.
It's the end of the day
and Julien and I are gonna go eat.
Stay tuned.
So we're heading to the sawmill again.
Yep, we are back in the sawmill.
This time to get the wood
for the walls of the pig trailer.
And of course we are gonna use
our beloved basketball court field.
This time we asked them to
remove the top layer with a planer.
To have a bit of color
variation inside the trailer
and to save us from
sanding the entire thing by hand.
Easy for them, easy for us.
Maybe the other way, yeah.
It's time now to focus on the
inside and to do the paneling of the wall.
Which is the last step for the walls.
We have here the same wood that
we used for the roof and the ground.
It's the basketball court wood.
Let's do it.
Since the wood is
second hand, it has already
been glued before
when it was a basketball field.
So we are working with
the materials that have some time
residue of some type of
glue, silicone, we already know.
But that means that sometime we
have to take an extra time to clean it.
This is a piece
98.6 and it goes right there.
Ah, finally done with the paneling!
It's all finished. We
only have some slight finishing to
do, especially on the
edges of the windows and the door.
Overall, it was very
long. It took us, I think, 8? No.
6 days to do
everything and we were 2 people.
So it was really long, but very
satisfying also, especially when it works.
Sometimes it doesn't
work, sometimes it works.
So yeah, finishing on the door
and the window and I think we're done.
And we can move on to the
next steps to make this a proper house.
Exciting!
The outside of our level 2 house is
finally finished. Let us know what you think.
And the inside is looking great.
There are still
some small things to do, such
as the sockets and
switches, install a stove...
Watch out for spoilers!
But that's for the next video.
Because now Alize is gonna do
something very cool for this toilet.
So this is the new compost toilet
we have been using for a couple of months.
Everything is
perfect, just sometimes we can't
really tell if there's
somebody using the toilet or not.
No!
So we think it would be a nice idea to
have a sign here to show the toilet vacancy.
Sorry!
So the idea is to
add a rotatable sign out on
the door, which is
connected with the indoor lock.
So every time when people lock
the door, the sign will turn into in use.
We'll make it into a little bird shape as
there is a lot of
birds living here around us.
We have been clearing mimosa trees
beside the road for the fire resilience purpose.
So we got a lot of mimosa wood here.
Let's pick some for the door lock.
So we have collected
some wood branches and we'll
start making the indoor
lock with these pieces of wood.
Now I'm using these tools to
create a flat surface on the wood branch.
So now we have a nice flat surface here.
Now we will apply some linseed oil
on the wood surface to protect the wood.
Now we are finish
with the indoor handle.
After finishing with the handle, I'm
making a draft of the little bird here on a
cardboard to see if the size
is a good fit on the actual door.
So now let's place the paper cut
bird here to see if the size fits or not.
I think the size is okay.
So here is a prototype of
how the lock is going to work.
So when the door is
unlocked, the bird will stand like this.
When we lock the
door inside, the bird will
turn down like
eating some seed on the ground.
So the bird lock is finished.
Let´s see how people use it.
Gui came on.
You can go.
It works.
Cool.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
So that's it for this video.
Next week we will finish the pig
trailer if you already want to see it.
Support us on Patreon.
If not, just subscribe.
Thank you for watching
and see you in the next update.